[Musique]
bedra des pierres mais sous ses pieds
bien parce que le niveau j'ai été bien
décorée coupe cerf-volant j'aime bien de
savoir s'il ya un éclair qui arrête les
clairs 1 6-10 et égouts et j'avais
jamais eu des cerfs-volants qu'au départ
le titre que les texans de 30 ans et
j'ai pas trop compris le sens du vent
[Musique]
c'est un petit garçon
liamine zeroual couple minaj bébé dans
son lit et un petit l'aiment d'autres
bénévoles et à travers les barreaux et
voilà le trailer sont reines du convoi
les marques de rouvrir soumis qui voyait
tout à travers et que y avait une image
où il était dans le ventre excité ça
fume dans 1900 je sais plus tard votre
enfant de cuisine et va dans l'espace
[Musique]
c'était bien dessinée que c'était beau
j'ai beaucoup aimé parce que l'état a
forcément des textes et ça change des
véhicules
en fait été un porteur du bread et des
lettres et des colis et un jour en fait
ils droit
trajet j'étais plein il faut il fait
plein de choses comme ça ne fera plus la
dae jung l'air ils voulaient attaquer un
facteur non quand il avait fallu moins
bien de la guinée sandwich d'un abri
[Musique]